bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon rubrique est indienne est
aujourd'hui avec stéphane laborde
bonjour stéphane bonjour et loire alors
nous allons étudier la variante critique
de l'ouverture est indienne l'est
indienne on en a déjà parlé il ya toute
une rubrique qui lui est dédié c'est une
ouverture d' attaque c'est une ouverture
on joue en contre on attend que les
blancs prennent le centre on laisse
volontairement avancé pour pouvoir
asséné une attaque violente sur le roi
est ici nous sommes donc dans le cas de
la grande variante stéphane c'est celle
où les blancs prennent tout le centre
est où on les attaque on est tous entrer
les noirs déboule sur les leroy avec
leurs pions et c'est la variante la plus
critique qu'ils soient dans l'east end n
est la plus intéressante ou alors
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est très
critiquée bien c'est parce que c'est une
variante à mort c'est du chaos
on ne peut pas faire mieux loup
pratiquement jamais c'est à dire que
s'ils attaquent des noirs réussi ils ont
gagné si elle échoue et bien tout
simplement ils ont perdu parce que de
l'autre côté et ils se font tout
simplement pulvérisé ses aucune variante
à double tranchant c'est la vente la
plus chaude de l'est indienne il faut
évidemment savoir l'algérie on va vous
montrer comment pas un jeu de pièces
précis en mettant les bonnes pièces au
bon endroit
les bons plans les bonnes manoeuvres et
bien on peut toujours réussir à trouver
du contre je aujourd'hui stéphane
nouvelle méthode nous avons pris trois
parties de kasparov trois références et
nous allons commenter tous les plans qui
sont récurrents kasparov avec les noirs
donc on va s'atteler à démontrer que les
noirs peuvent gagner que le nord sont
mieux n'était pas forcément facile alors
tout de suite nous allons mettre la
position et vous présenter cette
variante principal en images avec des
coups avec des pièces avec des cases
c'est parti les blancs jouent des quatre
donc amené six normales c'est le coût
normal que l'estonienne sélestadienne
cavaliers f3 bon là il peut y avoir
c'est 4 d'abord mais dans la grande
pariente on peut jouer cavalier f3
puisqu'on n'a pas besoin de bouger le
pion f nous allons laisser en f2
contrairement à stéphane ce qu'on a vu
dans les quatre pions ou là ces niches
ouais j'ai 6 on ne change pas le plan
c'est toujours la fameuse stratégie sur
quasiment ce qui caractérise les stars
viennent c'est ce fonds fiant kétou qui
joue sur la grande diagonale
tous ces coups stéphane nous a déjà
expliqué donc on va pas s'attarder
dessus non d'autant plus qu'avant
principal très très longue
donc ces cas on installe des pions vers
le centre j'essaie
quel c3 c3 pour jouer aux quatre petit
rock de 4 ça y est c'est l'installation
les blancs ont envahi le centre des 6 et
maintenant ils mettent le roi à l'abri
avec foucault 2 donc tout ça c'est bien
connu que cinq petit rock
on avait déjà vu la voir des changes qui
consiste à échanger le pion aux cinq
salles il ya pas de petits rorquals et
on a vu que ce n'était pas dangereux
pour les noirs d'ailleurs tout à fait
donc là les blancs essaie de consolider
le centre d'attaqué vers le centre après
qu'ali c6 il joue le coup des scènes qui
ferme le centre des cinq firmes le
centre les noirs répond naturellement
par cabello 7éme maintenant la structure
de plomb est figé les blancs ont des
pions orienté vers la gauche de
l'échiquier les noirs c'est le contraire
une première première remarque stéphane
les noirs sont orientés vers le roi et
demi alors que les blancs sont orientés
vers le vide vers le vide en finale
dames mais si les noirs n'arrive pas à
démontrer une attaque sur les leroy et
bien l'initiative des blancs elle d'un
va être terrible exactement
il faut donc réagir alors là les blancs
ont le choix nous avons déjà étudié la
variante b 2 b 4 c'était avec jean-luc
chavanon donc dans l'est évidemment
archives de diagonale de leçons toujours
la rubrique est indienne vous pouvez
trouver la tacc baïonnette
c'est le cas où les blanches ou b4y six
autres cas le coût principal la fameuse
variante principal c'est ce coup
caballero un idée première
on libère la dame est fou et nous
évitons que les noirs jouent kapadia
chic ça c'est la première idée
deuxième idée nous allons l'expliquer
tout de suite
le cavalier partie de f3 il est venu sur
la case 1 il va venir sur la case d3 et
ici le cube stéphane un poste très
important parce que ils contribuent à la
poussée c4 s'exprime en laye control4
ccn qui permet de jouer ces 4 c 5 et
super valais peut aussi revenir dans
certaines variantes en défense
exactement c'est ce qu'on verra en
passant par détroit puis en revenant à
f2 c'est tout à fait la partie c'est une
partie de hyères où une piquette contre
garry kasparov vers une piquette qui est
le meilleur joueur hollandais
sinon le deuxième cas validé cette
pourquoi l'explication est assez simple
il faut jouer avec les noirs la taxe sur
les droits donc il faut libérer le plan
f
voilà l'idée c'est de jouer 7 5 et 7 5
on remarque dans cette position que nous
avons le choix mais il faut suivre le
plan on peut jouer aussi cardio 8 mai
qui avait dix huit serait moins fort
stéphane puisque ça nous contrôlent pas
l'avancée des blancs c4 c5 donc
comparativement ici quand vous avez
cette position vous dites il faut que je
joue f5
je dois donc bouger mon cavalier pts 6
on a le choix des cases et là ce qu'il
faut ce dire eh bien c'est que nous
venons sur la case utile
c'était un la case 17-10 non seulement
contribuer à jouer 5
mais en plus retarde la tacc des blancs
en contrôlant la casse ces cinq une fois
de plus c'est très important
les blancs dans cette position on un
premier embranchement il faut voir ils
ont deux coups possibles l'idée de toute
façon va être de jouer le coup c4 c5
voilà donc il faut protéger cette avance
alors premiers coups possibles stéphane
séguin et détroit et le coût de la
partie c'est fou et 3 alors nous allons
regarder les deux mais dans cette partie
on va se concentrer sur le coup
fou c'est un endroit coûtera logique
pour contrôler le casting exactement et
finalement poussé le pion f5
alors là ce qu'il faut voir très
important surtout en pro f 5
comment on reprend et bien
systématiquement au quasi
systématiquement du pion c'est une règle
dans l'east indienne pourquoi on reprend
du pied et bien parce qu'après le
cavalier hausse est l'avenir sur la tête
j'ai six la dame va donc être libéré
pour arriver côté roy le cavalier angers
6 est très forte ce qui peut aller soit
en f4 soit en h4 ces deux casques les
l'attaquent devient extrêmement fortes a
noté kissy prendre du cavalier c'est
aussi intéressant puisqu'on nous ne
sortions mobile au centre aussi ça c'est
tous les avantages faute positionnelle
pour les blancs la prison f5 c'est
quasiment toujours mauvais dans cette
position à cause de la reprise y plonger
et du câble et qui vient sur l'a4 à
l'est à il ya une menace des noirs c'est
de jouer f4 qui obligerait le froid
partent en retraite voilà il est blanc
perdrait du temps c'est donc pas
acceptable c'est pas du tout dans l'idée
des blancs si votre adversaire de poule
3 c'est dans cette position pour jouer
le f2 f3 l'idée c'est que sur f4 on joue
fèves 2 ici il faut se poser la question
avec les noirs qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comment on attaque et bien il faut
pousser les pions il faut pousser les
pions donc on va pousser les pions f
et on va pousser leturgie il n'y a pas
d'autre
possibilité c'est à dire qu'ici nous
avons établi une tension au centre ça
c'est systématique dans les stades yann
les pions f5 et e4 se regarde droit dans
les yeux les blancs ne sont pas pressés
en cas de prise en main 4 ils reprennent
systématiquement du pion ils consolident
leur centre et les normes plus de
perspectives d' attaque ce n'est donc
pas une option
les bleus vont tranquillement pousser
ses cinq et nous attaquer il faut donc
trouver un moyen de continuer notre
attaque sur le roi et demi on joue donc
le couvert 5 à 4 les blanches houphouet
f2c leurs idées et maintenant continuer
la tac avec g5
donc ça c'est typique c'est le début
dans la vente principal dès que votre
adversaire à fermer le centre ça se
passe comme ça l' attaque on bouge le
quatrième six ensuite on joue f5
on joue f4 et on joue g5 stéphane voilà
j'ai cinq pour jouer g4 a pris mais pour
l'instant on peut pas parce que là cette
case g4 est très bien contrôlé par les
blancs par le client est roi le fougueux
et la dame d un voile à contrôler sur
diagonale évidemment on ne peut pas le
pousser tout de suite mais c'est l'idée
des noirs il faut un jour réaliser cette
percée on va voir que c'est long mais
d'un autre côté ce qu'il faut voir si
stéphane c'est que les blancs eux n'ont
pas vraiment commencé leurs attaques
oui il va falloir jouer b4 va enfin
jouer ces 5
c'est une course de vitesse pour essayer
d'affaiblir elle d'amd bout des noirs b4
tout de suite très logique on veut jouer
ces cinq là moyen mnémotechnique pour
vous rappeler du coup dans cette
position vous n'êtes pas obligé de vous
rappeler normalement vous pouvez le
retrouver sur l'échiquier avec les
principes on va vous donner quand vous
ne pouvait plus empêcher ces 5
c'est un signe c'est le moment de
ramener le cavaly 17 sur les thèses m6
est ici c'est le cas jouer b6 c'est une
faute positionnelle quand on est attaqué
d'un côté plus on bouge - c'est bon oui
ça c'est un principe de contre-attaqué
il attaque et la meilleure défense la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
kerviel si on pouvait plus empêcher ces
cinq de toute façon le key dans dix-sept
n'avait plus aucune utilité on voit
qu'avec ce coup stéphane on libère deux
pièces pour laquelle j'ai quatre mois
elle c'est pas mal déjà
donc si on va voir si on rajoute par
exemple le pian h qui peut venir acheter
éventuellement on peut pousser g4 ça ça
va arriver ça va arriver très très vite
ces 5 les blancs ont dû contre jeu
comment ils sont
des poils aux contres jeu des blancs et
bien c'est très simple kate l'a très
bien fait en général on prend des six on
joue autour c1 et ensuite le cavaly b5
et on essaie d'arriver sur la cassette
avec des menaces qui commence à être
important puisqu'on menace une tour
garry kasparov dans cette position doit
se poser la question comment je continue
de l'attak
et là il arrive à mettre en jeu une
pièce supplémentaire
il ya un plan tout à fait classique dans
cette position on ne peut pas vraiment
amélioré nos pièces il ya un moyen de
tourner la position des pièces qui est
assez original mais pour voir ça on va
voir ça tout de suite l'idée
l'idée en règle générale c'est que
l'option des six est faible il faut le
défendre en même temps la tour et 8 ne
participe pas à la taxe
il faut la mettre en joue alors tout ça
ça ne dit pas grand chose pour l'instant
où je câblée getis c'est le premier coup
puis on prend des six pions prend des
six tours c1 comme l'a dit avec le plan
pour le cavalier p5 et qu'avait laissé
sept exactement
hélas le coup de défense latérale touré
recette pour attirer pas mal joli coup
oui qui permet une qui n'a l'air de rien
mais qui est un coup d'épée à la fois
défensif dans un premier temps dans un
deuxième temps c'est aussi défensif
parce que le fou g7 va pouvoir revenir
sur la case et suis protégé le pion des
six essais tout va pouvoir coulisses et
angers 7 voire éventuellement acheter
plus tard pour participer à l'attaqué et
en même temps elle le défend la casse et
donc c'est la double emploi quasiment un
trip l'emploi triplé puisqu'elle permet
un effectivement de défendre la casse et
7,2 de faire passer le fou donc ça c'est
important si elle a libéré une case et 3
de passer à l'offensive
donc c'est un coup très constructif
c'est une manoeuvre typique dans la
vente principal de cette indienne il
faut absolument vous familiariser avec
cette possibilité qui est donc tour f7
les blancs jouent un coup d' attaque à 4
est maintenant en fuite
ça c'est la base fluide donc double
intérêt en protège le pion des six
puisque de toute façon le foin g7 ne
n'avais plus d'avenir au moins qui
servent en défense et on libère la casse
g7 pour la tour laquelle j 7 et stéphane
lacaze h7 dans certains cas les blancs
continuent leurs attaques en rond à 5
l'idée maintenant devient très simple
ils veulent jouer qu'amélie b5 prendre
le pion à 7 et rapatrient leurs fiefs de
sur la thèse b6 pour libérer un peu
d'air autour de leurs droits c'est donc
un
en même temps d'attac puisqu'on va
manger un pion et en même temps de
défense puisqu'on va libérer de l'espace
et la gare était pas toujours un coup
subtil un coup très subtil normalement
le joueur moyen qui arrive
qu'est-ce qui va jouer dans cette
position est bien grèce d'hier j'attaque
ça y est je fais à chaque match tant que
c'est pas une très bonne possibilité
pourquoi bien parce que garry kasparov a
vu quelque chose de très fins il joue
fou 17 dans cette position il dit à irin
piquette
c'est à toi de jouer et je parie que tu
as fait une connerie
donc c'est pas tout à fait ça mais les
blancs pour continuer leur attaque joue
donc cavalli b5 c'est normal et là ils
lâchent la défense des pions de 4 ce qui
permet donc la caritas portes de jouer
dans cette pression ou g5 g4 voilà même
si le pion est en prise c'est le pion
aux quatre qui se force aurait ramassé
ce qui serait un désastre d associer la
case de 4 qui tient la position des
blancs en plus le fief de sport aux
prises le fus f2 est la pièce la plus
importante des blancs est effectivement
une fois qu'on a joué plus reprend j'ai
quatre cavaliers profusion de 4 les
noirs ou deux pions mobile oak centre
c'est tout simplement terminer g4 dans
cette position les blancs ont de l'attak
et ils le font savoir juke a blessé sept
très normal pourquoi ce coup est très
fort puisque 1 on a tu as fais toi vite
et deux menaces de jours travaillés
aussi ce qui est souvent un trade très
embêtant puisque on en est quasiment
obligé de prendre avec le fou oui et
dans ce cas-là ça libère complètement le
centre pour les blancs
chose très importante dans cette vente
de l'est indienne vous allez le voir
tout à l'heure un plan d' attaques
extrêmement fort pour les noirs c'est de
juger 3 est passée la dame sur la case
h4 on va voir guérites et sport phare
réussi à le faire et là les blancs ne
doivent pas défendre et quatre ans en
tout cas ils ne doivent pas avoir cette
possibilité
et pour cela il faut absolument qu'on
est encore notre fou de cases blanches
pour pouvoir le sacrifier vous allez
voir on sacrifie tout de toute façon
donc c'est pour ça qu'il m'a dit aussi
s'en fait un coup de défense très fort
oui puisque une fois qu'on a supprimé ce
fou quatre manches les blancs ont de la
défense donc quand vous avez ce genre de
position avec les noirs principe
capitale ne jamais donner ce fou de
cases blanches
sinon votre attaque ne marchera pas ça
c'est une des premières choses qu'on
apprend aux joueurs des stars viennent
le fou s'est vite foot cases blanches
dans l'east indienne dans l'attaqué
contre le roi blanc c'est la pièce la
plus importante si cheikh disait
je joue au foot et 8 pour faire maths
j'ai arrêté c'est expéditif j'ai trois
jeux par garry kasparov qui donc ici
sacrifie fini j'aurai donc sa tribu
alors là ça a l'air curieux soukous g3
puisque les blancs me semblerait pour
pouvoir prendre ici oui alors c'est
toujours possible de prendre en g3 c'est
une variante effectivement l'analyse et
puis on prend ces trois là ya en général
deux possibilités mais bon de toute
façon mon projet 3 l'autre possibilité
c'est qu'un média le 5 mai ici je crois
pas que ça marche le coup préparé par
garry kasparov ses proches dont la
reprise en g3 les blancs maintenant a
priori ils vont très fou prend ça paraît
logique
oui et là on joue cavalier h5 les pièces
se déploie on attaque le foot est roi on
menace de passer la dame
on peut également revenir avec le fou
sur la case h6 ça c'est très fort donc
ça c'est une possibilité qu'il faut pas
négliger même dans cette position-là
fasciste tout de suite menace pour trois
échecs menaces france est un beaucoup de
possibilités donc vous voyez que dans ce
genre de position a priori cavaliers h1
kelkoo les pièces noires se déploie très
vite
en plus on a toujours tour g7 suivie de
cavani f4 attaque champions j'ai deux
menaces cavaliers h3 tchèque menace de
passer la dame angers 5
les pièces noires et s'ils sortent comme
des ressorts tout simplement
donc après j'ai trois iront une piquette
commence à paniquer c'est normal du joug
garry kasparov qui est quand même le roi
en cette position le maître incontesté
john caby prend 1,8 gagnant une tour et
garry kasparov ici ne va pas reprendre
ce cavalier
il se dit ça sert à rien et puis en plus
une fois que j'ai pu le cavalier éloigné
madame de l'attak
oui et ça c'est pas bien non dans cette
position le matériel ne compte plus il
faut l'attaqué à tout va
c'est la seule solution stéphane pour
espérer s'en sortir tout à fait grands
principes importants également dans ce
genre de position c'est nocif d'hoffmann
nous l'a appris dans les stades yann
variante principal si les blancs échange
les dames toutes les finales sont
perdantes pour les noirs oui c'est
difficile puisque là
là le pion faible des six n'a pas de son
équivalent chez les blancs ça c'est un
fait
l'autre fait c'est évidemment stéphane
que les noirs jouent le mat et sandales
n'y a pas de matt williams 6-1 et si
comme on l'a dit ça passe ou ça casse
donc si on peut pas mates et bien nous
allons perdre ici garry kasparov ne perd
pas de temps à les reprendre ce cavalier
il veut garder des possibilités pour
saddam
de l'autre côté c'est logique cavaliers
h5 commenge 5 menace d'un match 4 trade
à lens damages 4 suivi du match suivi du
mat
et si les blancs jouent h3 dans ce cas
là on sacrifie le fou 17 par exemple
mettons que game piquette joue le coup
franc à 7 et un coup comme un autre on
joue des matches 4 menace d'un prof de
maths menace nat
on voit que les blancs peuvent pas faire
d' espaces pour le roi donc il faut
jouer h 3 h 3 et forcé puisque surtout
engranger trois ans j'aurais pu on prend
et mat quand même hélas le coup
thématique fou proches 3 on n'a pas peur
ici les pièces ne valent rien la seule
chose qui compte c'est le nat des
menaces ou prendre j'ai deux menaces vos
projets de sacrifier encore le fou
mediamath suite d'un match de maths
surtout on prend on prendre la dame
stéphane ya maths et on se demande de la
défense
l'ananas et damages de maths surtout à
faisait là c'est très sain pour prendre
la tour
roy prend la suite se passe de
commentaires si vous êtes un peu habitué
avec les stars diane et bien vous
trouverez les coûts de vous même ça peut
être dame j'ai trois chèques c'est
peut-être quadrillage 4 ça peut être
tour g7
il ya suffisamment de matériel pour que
ce soit sur d'asséner un échec et mat
tout à fait ici donc après cavaliers h5
la menace ces dames h quatre piquets
djourou h
et donc nous allons passer assez vite
sur la fin de la partie pour pouvoir
vous rencontrer une autre ici garry
kasparov et une attaque colossal une
jupe surprend f2 tout reprend oui parce
que ces attaques et le cavaly ces
attaques le cavalier qui fait dames
c'est pas très important de faire dame
mais ça ramasse une pièce pour preuve
deux vérités sport vous pourrez jouer
d'impro à 8 avec une position sans doute
gagnante puisque on fait un bilan
matériel ici les noirs ont quand même
deux pièces pour une tour après tout à
fait ça c'est un avantage kenyans mais
mary kasparov est un esthète de l'est
indienne ils tous donc allégé trois
chaînes thématiques
ça se passe sur case noire ou encore une
fois si on prend le cavalier le pion g3
revient escape range étroit et on a
encore lui le thème du mat avec à mach 4
toujours en nous qu'il est très
important de laisser cette dame
endémique le plus longtemps possible
ici après 3g un direct et sport joue
dame prend habite toujours sur pied un
projet 3 on reprend si la tour bouge on
ramène la dame tout simplement et on a
le temps on peut jouer aux dames des
huit tranquillement et je ne vois pas
comment les noirs peuvent empêcher les
blancs peuvent empêcher d'un match 4 les
blancs ne peuvent rien faire dans cette
position vers une pique à des juifs ou
c4 et la garry kasparov fini avec une
petite un petit replacements de pièces
il joue à six dames détroit et damas est
damas est superbe sur 15 mois on allait
en éliminer le fou blanc de cases noires
et maintenant la dame aura sept exerçait
un rôle très important à la tête le roi
elle attaque la tournée on va voir que
ça se termine très vite après b 5 pions
prend fou prend cavaliers h1 la petite
pointe la tourette attaquer si le roi
prend le cavalier la dame vient ramasser
la tour avec une pièce de plus entière
évidemment plus la tac s'est donc
terminée donc voilà une très belle
partie de garry kasparov
on va revoir tous les plans au ralenti
stéphane on va se remettre au début
puisqu'il faut la revoir cette partie
dans cette position c'est comme ça dès
le début votre adversaire a donc joué
dans cette position de base cavaliers
key 17 pour empêcher ces cinq et pour
jouer f5 fouet 3 f 5 f 3 ar 3 quasi
obligatoire parce qu'elles captent manas
elle est menacée f4 quand même fou f2
les blancs ont rapatrié leurs fous mais
ils ont perdu du temps j'ai 5
on continue des quatre cavaliers pts 6
ça ne sert plus à rien de contrôler ces
cinq donc il faut évacuer ces cinq quand
même qualifié 6
le fameux plan qui est destiné à jouer
tous rêvent 7 stéphane est fou et fuite
extrêmement fort plan extrêmement
puissant extrêmement classique dans les
stades
si on prend des six comprend tour c'est
un les blancs font leur attaque comme
ils peuvent
tous rêvent sept coups de défense coûte
défense à quatre fois fuite
le coût qui permet à la tour de
coulisser à 5
hélas le coup mal un fou 17 les blancs
n'ont pas vraiment d'autres coûts que
calais b 5 qui lâche donc la défense du
pian 4 et maintenant c'est l'heure de g4
et une fois qu'on a fauché quatre la
menace évidemment stéphane cg3
sacrifiant un pion
ouvrons toutes les cases noires prenant
toutes les cases et c7 g3 quand même et
la suite on l'a vu on la revoit quel
point huit cavaliers h5 menace d'un
match 4 ce fameux thème du mat avec le
food et cette pièce très importante à ne
pas oublier
je crois qu'on peut voir un autre
exemple nous allons voir tout de suite
un autre exemple effectivement donc la
partie
diouf ehrhoff contre garry kasparov
vieille partie mais cissé g6 toujours
pareil donc là les premiers coups on est
comme en plus puisqu'on les a déjà
commenté
c'est un autre ordre de combat c'est
pareil petit rock qu'elle c6 des cinq
cavaliers cette cavale yeux un cahier 17
pour l'instant c'est pareil pour
l'instant c'est pareil sauf que la lada
à face est fou et 3,3 ici qu'elle et
détroit un petit peu différent pas tout
à fait pareil
on joue donc f5 très logique food et
deux oui parce que là maintenant fouet
trois souffre douleur tories arrive
quatre oui on n'a pas joué f3 et comme
c'est très important pour les blancs
d'avoir la tour en c1 pour l'attak
eh bien il joue naturellement food et
deux dans cette position on rejoue
cavaliers apsys il ne faut pas jouer
avec 4 maintenant ça serait une faute
positionnelle grave stéphane puisque les
blancs pourra jouer fou aux deux ans
j'ai 4 way et par ce coup il nous force
aurait donc à échanger les fous de cases
blanches et quand il ya plus de
footloose blanche il ya plus d attaques
donc ne pas vous tromper dans cette
position il faut absolument jouer
cavalier six attaques le pion aux quatre
là on menace de le prendre
et quand les blancs ont joué trois coups
force et maintenant et uniquement
maintenant jouer f4 parce que il n'ya
plus food sur la 4g 4 qui permettrait
aux blancs d'échangés la pièce matt
maîtresse des noms tout s'est vite qui
peut toujours se sacrifier en 1 h 3 pas
de blague donc je vois bien calés m6
avant la f4 ses 500 c'est le même thème
on n'a pas joué b4 avant mais c'est le
même thème c'est normal puisque stéphane
si lecavalier il est là et on a forcé
les noirs à rognan m6 avant g5 donc là
comme en a plus beaucoup de temps nous
allons apprécier la tête de kasparov
tout simplement sans faire trop de
commentaires si on prend des six qui on
prend cavaliers f2 donc là on l'avait
dit
il est blanc vont contrôler à mort la 4g
carte avec le faux 2 la dame d un le
câble ni deux le pion f3 et même le pion
à choix donc ça va être méga contrôle
mais ça ne suffira pas quel j'ai six
races et du même coup paul morin a pour
les noirs c'est facile c'est toujours
pareil vous allez voir encore à 4 et là
on vous donne 5 secondes
le plan qui tue qui attaque qui défend
et qui regroupe tous rêvent 7 7 km et 5
h 5
pourquoi pas à chaque but il faut
pousser g4 donc là on note que sur
qu'elle les prend à 7
évidemment on se fout 17 en courant
parce qu'il faut pas donné se fout donc
ça c'est clair
après h 5 h trois fois fuite
on laisse le pion à cette emprise si les
blancs prennent ce pion ils perdent
énormément de temps ils ne pourront plus
vite et j'ai 4 après dame ces deux
l'idée dans cette pression c'est de
jouer tour f en c1 faire de l'air pour
le roi et en même temps je me cassais 7
puis stéphane une fois qu'on en sait
cette rébellion en russie on ne prend
pas la torah vite on préfère plutôt
aller en russie dans la majeure partie
des cas pour tuer ce fou à 6 donc avant
que le kawaii n'y arrive cavaliers à 3
tours j'ai sept mérités sports phil
envoie tours fc 1 est là comment on fait
pour essayer d'avancer g4 dans des
meilleures conditions et bien on libère
d'action de la tour avec cavalli h4 les
plans c'est toujours les mêmes et
l'efficacité est monstrueuse
voilà on veut que la tour est très bien
placé pour l'attaqué et la défense d'âme
des uns un coup logique les blancs ont
libéré la casa fin pour le roi et
maintenant ils reviennent à fond
contrôler la case du 4 voilà et c'est là
que gary kasparov
il sait très bien ce qu'il faut faire il
faut temporiser toujours il joue fou 17
avant ça c'est important et sur pied ces
quatre seulement maintenant g4 donc il
joue toujours fous 17 avants g4 kasparov
ça a son importance dans énormément car
c'est un sacrifice puis en projet quatre
pions prends moi noté culture 1 4 est en
prise mais il est défendu par lequel il
de stéphanie ce qu'elle arrive de qui
protège ça c'est la différence avec le
fou qui ont franchi 4 et maintenant
festival festival de sacrifices
garry kasparov
lemaitre qui sait exactement comment
faire marcher la position comment faire
pour que toutes les pièces se déploie on
voit un gros potentiel on voit une
d'amendé vite qu'ils demandent pas mieux
que d'arriver en rage 4 sur les cases
noires qui sont toujours très faibles
côté blanc latour angers c'est très bien
placé le camion m6 le fou en dessert
quel virage 4 tout ça c'est très beau
mais finalement ça ne marche pas
ensemble il faut trouver le truc est là
donc sacrifice de kasparov double
sacrifice de kasparov qu'étrangers 2 mai
donnant un cavalier mais tout ça donc
après trois projets dont on voit que
déjà l'efficacité de la tour sur le roi
s'est avancé d'un cran ou à venir avant
il y avait deux options devant et là tu
en prends le deuxième qui est branché 4
donne encore un cavalier fou pranger
quatre fous projet 4 et là il ya plus de
défense et filles c'est vraiment très
simple donc iuf ehrhoff a joué d'un
projet car la question ses caves à
l'étranger 4 stéphane meyer et d'un
masque à tout simplement
c'est très simple dames des beats en h4
la voilà menaçante pour quand j'ai
quatre imparable le master projet car il
n'y a pas de défense
il ya un match qui suit est aussi
d'alger 3 remet tout reproche et 4 celui
de la dame avec dame et tour on arrive à
mater dans cette position donc surfer
ravage l'est d'avranches et 4 mais si ça
ne pose pas de problème à garry kasparov
et je vous reprends cavaliers prend on
compte simplement le matériel il ya tour
et deux pièces pour la dame donc ça a
l'air mieux pour les blancs mais la
position du roi blanc est tellement
déplorable qu'il n'y a eu aucun problème
à garry kasparov pour transformer cette
position il a joué tour s'est vite et la
partie s'est suivi tranquille
donc on récapitule stéphane deux
possibilités dans cette langue
principale une fois que les blancs jouer
cavalier e 1 soit avec fo 3 soit gagnée
3 ces deux plans différents
ouais mais pour les noirs c'est toujours
pareil il ya le plan clé il ya le plan
clé toujours joué s4 en empêchant fou
j'ai quatre exactement et ensuite j'ai 5
g 4 au bon moment il faut attendre le
bon moment
oui et surtout tous rêvent cette fois
fuite et qu'elle g6 qui défend tous
donc voilà revoyez ces deux parties
entraînez vous vous pouvez les jouets
vous pouvez les revoir elles sont très
instructives très intéressante donc
stéphane on se donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
ouais pour une nouvelle émission
diagonale la leçon qui sera sur le thème
de la ccil and nash doivent donc
nouveaux thèmes abordés dès la semaine
prochaine
on vous remercie de nous avoir suivis